i was drawn to the senior level work
because
i have a passion for leadership i know
that great leaders
make the difference in an organization
[Music]
jenny clark thank you for being on my
show how are you i'm doing great michael
thanks for having me
no no thank you for being so generous
with your time i really really
appreciate it it's also very early
and so so i really appreciate you taking
the time for this
ginny i can't wait to to learn all about
you know
your your leadership experience your
staffing experience and
the the non-linear route that you took
to get to where you are
and and the the things you're passionate
about especially you know diversity
in in leadership and in recruiting so so
jenny why don't you take us back to
the early days where do you come from
and and how do you get
to be a leadership staffer at google
after doing so many different other
things
sure i'm happy to it's uh it's kind of
an interesting story i've told it many
times but i'm very tired of hearing it
actually so i hope your audience will
appreciate it
i grew up in riverside california i
wanted to be a veterinarian so i went to
uc davis
uh to study animal science and after a
couple of quarters of studying that i
switched to french
and then literally flipped through the
catalog to fortify that and so i landed
on linguistics so i got a degree in
french linguistics
i'd always been very active on campus
worked in the chancellor's office peer
advising counseling all that stuff
and i took a job at the university at uc
davis
as a recruiter recruiting for the
university of california system
did that for two years and my dad really
wanted me to go to law school
um my brother did that fortunately so i
went to business school
and i kellogg i moved to chicago um
people you know as a californian people
were like
why would you do that it's cold i'm like
because else
you got their codes for that right um i
had the best time at kellogg i was on
the admissions committee
um as a as a first year student um i
worked in the admissions office
i was very active and then when i
graduated they actually offered me a job
in admissions which is you know kind of
like recruiting right
and i said no no i have to go into
business so i went into banking
at what was then called first chicago
it's now chase um i spent a couple years
doing it i got exposed to commercial
real estate and pivoted into commercial
real estate with
what's now jll used to be known as
lasalle partners back in the day
um i did that for a few years um went
over to prudential in their real estate
investment management arm
um and then my dad died in the early 90s
and that was one of those defining
moments where i just questioned
everything about what i'd been doing
and he had been i had amazing parents
both of them um but he was really my
coach
he'd call me every sunday morning and
and cheer me on
and um so after he passed i just said
you know what is it that i've always
really
loved to do and i neglected to mention
that when i was working for these other
companies
that i actually went on site to recruit
for them i was not a recruiter but
that's what i offered to do
and so i write i wrote a book called
career mapping and in the book i write
i left breadcrumbs for myself and so i
went back
and said i want to be an executive
recruiter um
i went i networked my way i was pretty
good at it
and i networked my way into one of the
largest executive search firm spencer
stewart and was there for 12 years
and became a partner co-founded leather
global diversity practice worked in
financial services and financial officer
practices
and i left in 2009 to write a book
wrote my book did consulting meanwhile i
have a son i got married
divorced um so i've been a mom through
all of this
and he's the light of my life and so i
i did my own thing for a number of years
about four years
and then i went back i had to get them
through college and i wasn't getting
that spencer stewart salary so
i decided to go to another search firm
that was in canada this this
is where it gets really interesting that
firm sold after about two years
um but one of the people that i had
recruited and worked with
uh when the company sold went to google
and 2016 he called me and said we need
help
because google had recently formed their
internal executive search firm with
people that i knew
including oh just just two for for the
bet for context when you say search firm
is that a company that is dedicated to
helping recruit people for for others a
search firm yeah
yes a search firm at the executive level
so it's not like an agency where
we're trying to place people it's quite
different we are
it's much more like management
consulting where
we get paid a pretty hefty fee to work
with big companies mostly large
sometimes small startups
but to find senior leadership talent um
so what is the difference between
finding right so what's the difference
between an agency that just
that places people in in all sorts of
positions versus you know finding
leadership
talent what is the difference over there
well it's
um it's much more of a how am i going to
describe this tactfully
i don't i don't want to impugn any other
agency but
at the leadership level most of the
people are passive
so it's not as though people are
applying for these jobs
we get a mandate we go out i would call
on big companies in the chicago area and
all over the country
um to say you know i understand you you
might be looking for a
chief financial officer um and so we'll
spend time with them to understand well
what does that mean that's not a one
size fits all and we don't just post it
and wait and see who applies
right we strategically do research to
identify what are the other companies
that are relevant
who might those the correct people be
for us to consider
go after them and woo them and pull them
in so it can be a lengthy
you know four to six month process
sometimes much longer
um to find those senior executives and
that's what we do inside of google as
well
no so i guess it makes sense because
then these are key people that are
that are you know they could be a make
or break for the company a good hire may
help the company a bad hire
may break the company especially this
especially the sea level
and above positions so so you up until
that point when you were
when you were and the two search firms
were you the one going and
and getting that mandate okay we need a
new cmo
and you're going out to the market and
saying okay let me go pull
in the right candidates and until we can
find the right one for you
that's right i did both things so um
it's professional services and so
but as i mentioned like in management
consulting you have to go get the
business
you have to find the client and then
right and then manage the engagement
with the you've got a researcher
typically sometimes an analyst who's
doing a deep dive what are the companies
who are the people what do we know who
we spoken to before
um this person might be great in a
larger organization
versus this one might be better in more
of a startup
um you know that that's got if it's got
a build to it
so one thing that i'm assuming though is
that c-level executives especially the
ones who are
you know right at the at the top of the
ladder they don't go on length and they
say i'm looking for my next opportunity
right
there is a good opportunity right now i
i might be wrong but it sounds like you
know some of the gems
are people that are not that are already
have great positions
and they don't even so they're not
actively looking and you have to sort of
understand if they're if they might be
interested right that's exactly right
and
when i started in the business linkedin
was was
didn't exist actually so um now
we do leverage it because there are
people who will kind of let you know i'm
looking for my next opportunity
or conversely people to reach out to
some of the executive search firms i had
lots of people
that would come to me and say hey i'm
looking for a job which if i can
pivot just so slightly on that point um
that's one of the reasons i wrote
this book career mapping it's because i
it concerned me that so many people
would come to me
as an executive recruiter um search
firms are working
they have an exclusive on whatever that
role is so it's
meaning it's not a multiple listing
service so i'm not getting a view of all
the open roles for a cfo
okay it's whatever my company might be
working on
so it worried me that people would think
about it that way and i thought you know
if i could help folks understand
that they own their careers and that
they should really be the ones
um not just going to me as a recruiter
right
them determining what they want then
leverage me and
others to help get into that role into
that company
i mean what is like the hardest
challenge of all this like the most
difficult part of this job
um you know what it is it's getting
my clients i have clients within google
or
when i was at spencer stewart some of
them you know my clients
to really do an assessment that is based
on competency
because a lot of people want to just
default to
well have they done it in another
company right
they might have done it really poorly
and no one wants to say that
yeah but it's my job to tease out
how well did they do it and so i ask
competency-based
questions and so it's not just did you
do it tell me
how you did it give me an example but
then how do you but then how do you
evaluate that if you're because you're
coming in to all sorts of different
businesses right and i'm sure that
within google as well
there's all sorts of different you know
areas
which you're not an expert and you're an
expert on leadership staffing
how do you go and help them map out the
competency questions
and evaluate objectively the candidates
there must be some interaction with the
team that's hiring right
oh totally yeah and that's a great
question it's spencer stewart and within
google we specialize
so at google i lead the non-tech team so
i have people who specialize
in finance in marketing in say okay and
not
all they do right so they really do get
to know the senior leadership market
and we stay in the market um identifying
who is top talent that we want to get to
know to the extent we don't already know
them and have a relationship with them
it's a relationship business much more
than it is of course
yeah definitely talk to me a little bit
about your expertise and
and diversity er staffing it's also
something that you're very passionate
about
what what does that mean to you um
you know a lot of it goes back to that
competency assessment
because i think if you think about it
corporate america
was not open to women just not that long
ago
right um it hasn't been with black lives
matter i think we've realized that a lot
of black and other underrepresented
racial minorities have not been
acknowledged we haven't always had some
of the educational requirements to get
in um
and so it's important to me that talent
is being assessed
fairly um and and and that's really the
cornerstone of my efforts and that's the
infrastructure that i've sought to build
within spencer stewart um and and even
at google that's that's really what it
is and people kind of
you know they look at me as an
african-american woman and kind of say
oh well you must know a lot of black
people you must know a lot of latinos
and or a lot of women
um and that's not the point it's not who
i know it's who yes who i can access and
i know how to access
but i would much rather teach my
recruiters how to access all of that
great talent right so it's not just
because that's pretty limited i can't
know everybody that
that makes no sense so to the extent
i've got specialists and that's what
i've been able to do at google and
spencer stewart was to build the
infrastructure that says
do your research and i insist our
clients
insist within google and elsewhere um
that we are showing them a diverse
pipeline of talent that is relevant okay
so
i think that's really an important point
this idea that you're showing them a
diverse
pipeline of of talent and which feeds
them into the decision but then
how what what's what are them the
roadblocks in the system right now
what are the bottlenecks that are making
it very difficult
to to have to do this properly because
obviously
with black lives matter and everything
that's been that's been surfacing this
year
there is an equality and i'm sure that
in in most areas
uh the pipeline is that the top of the
funnel is still doesn't have
your diversity so what so what where is
the bottleneck right now
um some of it is in identifying people
and then i
i want to believe that my recruiters are
doing a great job um
and we we have metrics and tools to
monitor that i can go in and see are you
meeting talent pool
right we have to kind of know you might
say for example
um i think black people in the united
states are roughly 12
of the population um based on a lot of
the senior leadership roles that we are
seeking
that's not going to be our bogey because
we're requiring
that people have a certain level of
education a certain level of experience
so the number is going to be smaller i
won't tell you what it is but it's
smaller
okay right makes sense but we still have
we're
to identify in that talent pool we're
trying to get to um a level that makes
sense
at a minimum right because that's going
to enjoy
that's got that's going to give us a
better level of certainty that we will
indeed
increase representation over time the
bottleneck
is really one of changing hearts and
minds and so this is i'm just going to
be real about this right
we i can build the best infrastructure
identify all these people
put them in front of all of these hiring
managers but if they have it in their
head because they haven't seen
a person who looks like me doing what
they do during their experience
it's hard for them to kind of believe
sometimes that person is going to be as
good as they need them to be
and so we're really trying to overcome
some of these latent
beliefs i'm not going to say these
people are racist but i am saying
that they've got some deep down it's
this notion of unconscious bias
so now more generally in a high level
how does the how does the ecosystem deal
with that because it's not just
i'm sure this is something that's
occurring with every company and i again
i don't think that it's it's necessarily
that the people are racist it's that
people have deep rooted
you know that through the years they
grow and they're watching certain
personas do certain things and then
even and then subconsciously they have a
cognitive bias that when they're looking
at a few candidates they'll prefer the
ones that they're more familiar with
that that looks just a little bit more
like them right like what they are
familiar with
right so how the high level it's
part of what we're doing is really
trying to build in some of the
safeguards so
you know my recruiters are trained to
challenge them to the extent that they
have done the competency assessment and
they
are convicted that this individual isn't
being qualified
um they i have their back to go in and
say
i gotta challenge you right there are
other failsafes along
the process um from the the hr business
partner to
um you know my senior uh people who are
trying to monitor all of this and so
uh we're doing the best we can and
there's a ton of training going on
for a lot of these hiring managers and
all these other people who are
the people the other interviewers right
who are doing the work they're not
professional recruiters but they're part
of the interview team
that might be working with and for the
hiring manager we're doing lots of
training for them to understand not just
competencies
but this whole notion of unconscious
bias well
so you've obviously been in several
industries so far and you've had various
various positions that we spoke about
earlier why
why go into a senior leadership staffing
after all where does this passion come
come from give me give me that brief
from from the book that you wrote
yeah well i you know i think it comes
from
watching my dad you know he was a prison
warden and i watched a lot of uh
young people that were under his in it
were incarcerated
um and because he was with the youth
authority so a lot of these people were
as young as i was at one point right and
and i saw the potential in them
and i saw how there was systemic racism
in in our justice system that was
causing some of them and they made bad
decisions
and so i think there's there's a little
bit of that in my mindset that says
i see the potential in people and so
i've always wanted to be able to
um unlock some of the potential that i
see i was drawn to the senior level
uh work because i have a passion for
leadership i know that great leaders
make the difference in an organization
we've all worked with
not so great leaders and we've you know
we've felt it personally and we've
watched the organization
um suffer that might be an overstatement
but
not perform as well as it could by
virtue of the leader right we're seeing
that
in government um so i think that
that's that's the other linkage that i
have i'm really really passionate about
leadership
and i think leadership has a lot of
different forms and that's part of um
part of the passion that i have around
being an executive recruiter and helping
my clients
see what good better and best looks like
even if it doesn't look like them
i love it so as i as i go on my own
entrepreneurial journey and a lot of my
friends who are watching this as they go
and when we and perhaps we form a
companies and businesses and we have to
choose the right people to go on this
journey with us
whether it's at the start or the end
what are some of the key insights that
you've gained over the years
you know assessing thousands of
candidates for senior level positions
what should i be looking for when i form
a partnership with with my co-executive
directors
or or chief financial officers in the
future what are some things that i can
you know as a bad recruiter that i am
right now what what are some key things
that i can keep in my mind
that you've already learned well here's
a real basic one
um don't just tap your network okay
don't because i think that's that can be
really limiting it's and and frankly
it's a little bit
egotistical to think that i know
everybody who's good no you can't
possibly
we live in a vast world right whoever
whatever you're building you know you
should be able to tap people
in other countries um talent looks like
everything they're brilliant people all
over the world so
make sure that you have a real talent
mindset and you
appreciate and understand people you
care about people the value they're
bringing the uniqueness that they're
bringing
that to me is really critical um and
then
more more tactically when you're
assessing people
look for things like one of my one of
the most important things that
landed with me after a couple of years
of being a spencer stewart was
self-awareness
um you know i'd hear a lot of people
saying i did this i did that
and and they were telling me what they
did but again they weren't telling me
how they did it and they seemed a little
tone deaf
in terms of you know it was all about me
um
and then in contrast i would talk to
people who they would own
the leadership and you know they held
people accountable
and they were able to talk about their
role in driving impact
but they also talked about the
compassion the empathy
um the awareness that they had for other
people the awareness that they had for
some of their own shortcomings
that's really attractive to me um
because that to me
is as at the at the heart of what true
leadership represents
i love it ginny 20 minutes go by so fast
but i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time
before we leave i have to ask you the
most important question i need three
words
that you would use to describe yourself
and and why you chose those three
specifically okay and i was a linguist
right so words really matter to me
um wonderful with bold
um i'm pretty fearless and bold um
much like my father i think i got that
from him i am
kind um i have a tough exterior but
people who know me
know that i'm really really kind at
heart big heart
and then the last thing i would say is
um
awakened and by that i mean i have a
very
deep and personal spiritual practice and
i'm i believe that i
am maybe i should say awakening you
never you're never done
but i've done a lot of work to
understand who i am what my purpose is
in the world
and i want to bring that into everything
that i do i love it is there room to be
to have good optimism regarding
diversity and leadership
in the country over over the next uh the
next i guess decade or so
yeah i wouldn't do this work if i wasn't
optimistic i mean there are bumps in the
road but i think
we are i think black lives matter for
example is something that is here to say
i think there's an awareness
that there's a lot of work to do but i
think
those of us who get it and and are
convicted
we'll see change jenny thank you very
very much this was inspiring
uh truly thank you and for your
generosity for your time
and continue doing the amazing work that
you're doing thank you michael you're
you're a jam i really appreciate you
thank you thank you take care
all right
you